[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
careful boys we are lucky enough to have
with us today mr chappelle lacy on the
show
welcome back welcome back welcome back
welcome back chappelle's back catch up
with this guy a little bit what's been
going on man uh whatever i want that's
tight
[ __ ] clapping for everything i saw i
saw you on tour doing music i wasn't on
twitter that was a
i made up a story that you're going all
over the world and i caught you in one
of the [ __ ] bars that you were at i
was in a box yeah we were
just playing for like five people
you should be a publicist now we're
touring the bar circuit
was that the original band that you were
telling us about last time no no no this
is a newer band so you ban hobbies was
it why are you playing or earlier when i
was younger oh okay yeah but this one is
more like punk right or something else
scott died right scott's dead right
didn't die like just go go get it
the table right now well i know because
i felt hot it's alive at every skating
rink thursday nights yeah that is true
that is true at the deadest part dude
thursdays are crap
i missed that part of vegas when it used
to always be disco every day you know
what i mean like isn't that still there
like you were there yeah where are you
joe how old are you bro
when i was a child they were still they
were still reminiscent of that era where
like you walk down and then like they're
playing disco and everywhere and people
were like there attending oh yeah dude
in the 90s
or was the music just playing it was
playing it was playing all the time yeah
and then people people looked like the
70s because you know like how like even
though you're in the 90s or 80s right
yeah people are still stuck in the 70s
so then there's still a lot of people
that dress that way
huh did you just go to like a disco
party maybe you went to a theme where
did i end up yeah no i was walking with
my parents
or was it one of those times you're
making up stories again no
he's not yours i'm on tour
[Laughter]
maybe you're watching a movie yeah yeah
that happens it happens as a child like
boogie nights with a huge dick in it
exactly
you guys don't remember going to vegas
in the childhood and seeing people in
disco clothes all the time and then like
the disco music being played in like the
the by the in the casino and all that
and then it's like you're just like uh
you don't know that that's the 70s and
it's out of date but then even because
dealers are wearing bell bottoms no but
the people they're still dressed that
way roller skating around for sure yeah
with all the chips joe joe was just
there was a theme party at the hotel
that night was like man the 70s week
wait was it happening all the time
as far as i remember i just remember a
lot of people still dressed that way you
should have went to the next hotel over
there doing future theme oh maybe that's
what it was
here we are in vegas what an interesting
find
i just how old were you a child and i
like how he doesn't give any sex i was a
child
you know how long you're a child for
it was you're a child right
late 80s early early 1990s right okay i
do feel that vegas had this vibe of
either cowboy or disco and then you go
in and maybe like the whole [ __ ]
scarface kind of feel yeah yeah yeah
yeah well they do have the rodeos like
every year oh you're right at the uh mgm
the disco road or yeah wherever well
south south south point is that what it
is yeah they have the rodeo championship
yeah yeah and i remember like when you
go up and down the strip
um everything was cowboy themed or like
something like that or yeah you walk in
and people are dressed up like like
[ __ ] saturday night fever [ __ ] yeah
yeah that's true yeah and i just thought
that that was the you know when you
watch movies about [ __ ] disco and all
that [ __ ] you thought you were living in
that area yeah and i was just like
probably wearing my oshkosh [ __ ]
overalls and [ __ ] like at uh circus
circus yeah and i and then um
i just missed that era of vegas my
casino yeah well that's a little bit
older but yeah oh cause that's like 80s
or 60s right
that was 60s 70s yeah yeah those [ __ ]
yeah that's my era vegas if i had to
pick one do you remember that's the one
you want sino bro
dude we love everything about it yeah my
buddy's opening a bar soon and i was
like dude you know i'm gonna be that guy
in casino who's like he was like you
give me another [ __ ] drink i know the
owner
they're gonna for sure take them
seriously oh yeah yeah
it's like a discovery zone though that
it's gonna be it is good
it's like at a jump zone and [ __ ] and so
it's the bar at the jump zone it is
bar the jump zone that sounds like one
of those fat tuesdays you know what's
the most ironic and funniest thing about
it i can't talk about it too much
because it's kind of top secret [ __ ]
you're like serious i am serious hey
make sure you get a gig for his ska band
you got it scott's living dog all right
dude we'll [ __ ] bring it back for a
night i feel like this is one of those
suits really if like if you jumped into
the wall you just get stuck i think
this thing's also really hot by the way
i don't know if i'm gonna make it all
day in this indoor skydiving yeah yeah
is that one hotter than the one you wore
yesterday it's like i'm wearing a space
blanket dude it's [ __ ] crazy in here
yeah it looks like you're purposely
trying to lose water weight quick yeah
you're like an undercover cop trying to
be an emmy award
wow
that's funny it's the glasses bro
i like this one though it's uh
man my uber driver was really impressed
by it really what did they say she was
just like
oh wow
do you think that's rude that they
comment no i love it yeah i will you
should be like hey don't talk about my
[ __ ] imagine i take myself that
seriously yeah you should but you know
what did you say mind your [ __ ]
business
it's so believable because of where
you're staying at the casino exactly
it's the weirdest thing ever true yeah
yeah no one would look at them crazy get
right up there that's fair i get out of
the elevator and everyone's just like
this is normal [ __ ] because there's so
many douche bags in the casino yeah
there's all these people would you type
on amazon douchebag fit
shout out to the chain though thank you
very much thank you that's a nice one 20
amazon i feel like you have a 1970s
mercedes diesel that's tiger print
and then the interior is is leopards
[Laughter]
we're mapping out his life right now so
what okay what kind of house have a car
because it's sold for crypto [ __ ]
horrible idea
yo isn't that [ __ ] [ __ ] up right now
oh boy where am i tripping it's over
dude i'm wearing gold to project
silver dude
so that's why the outfit is okay that's
fair yeah yeah it's pain it's pain
to cover up his losses he has to look
rich you know he's helping him i have to
look like i'm going into space because
i'm never going to go to the moon in my
life oh
that's what he was hoping for
damn man damn
it hurts so what you've been up to dude
me oh
chilling touring uh
so you are tour
but no no no no
comedy oh comedy mostly comedy yeah he's
like every weekend you get booked every
weekend almost yeah pretty much yeah i
do a lot of shows around town and then
then i'll hit the road on the weekends
what how many uh how many stops how many
shows are in a tour so it's like weird
because like with comedy like you tour
just the weekends if you're doing the
club circuit you're doing the club
circuit then you just tour weekends but
like
if you when you start to tour like
theaters and
arenas and stuff like that then you're
like every day not every day but through
the week yeah is that like all around us
or yeah well i mean like go to miami
next
where yeah yeah is that where i go next
yeah i go to mike when you get booked
for all these shows are you really
excited about it like or is it like more
like damn i gotta travel no no i'm
actually pretty excited about it because
uh you know i'm at a point in my career
where i'm starting to get like you know
this traction with these clubs and stuff
like that so i'm just starting to get in
i'm not like selling like a ton of
tickets yet
hey when i get that suit though
[Laughter]
that's when we'll know it's over
it didn't work out like hey guys can't
get on your podcast again
he thinks this is the podcast
it's even worse for us
he shows up here in the same outfit as
you but oh [ __ ] it's all going to [ __ ]
it's starting to it'll
[Laughter]
the best part of this room is they were
all jealous of my jumpsuits actually oh
they weren't oh yeah they're all like oh
i was mad he didn't tell me because we
could have [ __ ] synced up outfits and
[ __ ] dude
yeah your boys have your back i know
they do they always do you are losing
your edge you're starting to look all
like normal and cool and stuff again hey
hey dude
did you see this though do you see this
i do see that do you see the tiger it's
the james
james
white is it original yeah
it's a freaking disabled tiger dude
yeah i was looking at it i was like damn
wait that tiger's [ __ ] up hardest is
disabled i got a down syndrome
i'm tired of seeing perfect tigers are
you lying there's really a story behind
this shirt you might as well you might
as well be
yeah he should be labeled something not
the might as well
jimmy said he might as well be disabled
james cage white got something oh [ __ ]
no he does
do you ever have to ask yourself
comedy
or music which one no well the beauty of
it is like
you know whenever
if i'm like having like writer's block
or something like that i can go pick up
the guitar you know and i keep
everything separate and then you know
when i don't feel like doing something
with music i'll just go
write yeah write some stuff or whatever
pressure on that yeah i have to have a
guitar right check this out
friday night you get booked
to do a comedy show or a music show and
you have to choose one comedy show okay
i'll make more money
do you know where my band is playing
right now
what if you made the same money same
audience
big show or like let's say like one's
[ __ ] oh so they're equivalent yeah
those copies one's at the coliseum
one's at the [ __ ] like mgm arena you
know it'll never be booked like that
right for scott
trying to paint a goddamn picture i
would never have ever that would
he said
some pictures can't be painted i like
real big fish
shall i say all right shout out yeah
i like that you guys could be the next
no doubt right we're not a sky man
that's like ska pop yeah it was yeah
yeah scott scott
yeah like let's say you that's why they
transitioned to punk
because punk is actually you'll get a
big but they still got trumpets they
turned into pop eventually broke the
eddie they turned eventually yeah
eventually you got to go into pop you
want to make money right yeah yeah yeah
you got to be avril but like let's say
oh yeah you gotta be a skater boy but
when you go pop that's right that's an
angsty teenager yeah that's olivia
rodrigo but that's hot though that's on
the screen
but yeah let's say you had the ultimate
music career or like there's a hollywood
genie that go like that
or our ultimate comedy career i guess
the easiest answer for that is i love
the stylings of donald glover
you know he has his hip-hop different
people yeah he has his his acting his
writing like he has all these layers to
him but he's able to like
like when you see childish gambino you
see childish gambino so you're gonna
have two names yeah do you have an aka
you'll have a chapelle
and a lapel
lapel is the sky guy yeah chappelle's
the chappelle scott pill
they booked the wrong guy they're like
oh we have chappelle tonight he's like
sorry man i'm lapel
dude i can't play bro can't play steve
martin just did banjo and stuff i think
he still does yeah he does
yeah him and martin short yeah they do
like a tour together where that's true
jackie chan also sings too so who that's
whack jackie chan did you say who
no like you caught me off guard
have goldblum do piano dude i've seen
jeff goldman do a lot of stuff jeff
goldblum's [ __ ] jazz band is like if
he had never acted and he was just a
jazz pianist he would still be a [ __ ]
that's like real [ __ ] yeah did you know
they have a massive statue for him i
think in like uh germany maybe
yeah him like laying down with like his
shirt out it's like massive it's huge
they have that from the meme
from the jurassic park meme is that what
it's from yeah where he's in the black
shirt he's all they come here
well yeah they made a statue of it in
germany unironically that's [ __ ]
legendary why did they do that i don't
know it's not david hasselhoff no oh i
know right
yeah yeah that's the people's i think
it's in germany don't they should put
that next to the wall street bowl not
the [ __ ] little girl going like this
it's a guy looking seductive yeah like
that's tight
[Laughter]
shit's so weird why couldn't it be a
woman at least like what's gonna be a
little girl staring at them like wall
street like she's gonna do something
what is this supposed to mean i don't
know yeah it wasn't me it's like girls
rule or some [ __ ]
like feminism
shouts out
hard on that one staring at wall street
yeah
i don't know
i honestly don't know
it's the little girl statue every every
day at 12 o'clock she goes like this
for a fist-up
girl's rule
i still feel like we can come up with
your aka here yeah let's do it you don't
like lapel what's wrong with that lapel
is a front runner lapels like water
i don't know i thought oh no sorry
that's propel
it's a great supplement it's like good
water propel now
what's your alias now for your ska stuff
and then maybe we can make it better i
don't have an alias
that people would call me
well they call you oh yeah uh people
used to call me uh confused
what
confused i don't know
like what's that guy doing at ska band
what's that guy doing in a scotland one
of my favorites was black as hell
chappelle
that's pretty fire yeah
they tried to use it as a disc but i
actually liked it i was like there's a
white guy that said it no mexican dude
mexicans with the disses man what else
what else what other what other ak's you
got uh black bones was a good one black
balls yeah
that sounds pretty horrible why yeah uh
sounds like a pirate i can't remember
why yeah it sounds like a pirate it does
sound like a pirate that's what it is
yeah right yeah yeah you used to have a
ship yeah i'm the captain now
do you ever ever get on stage and then
they go what's security doing with the
guitar
what's the bouncer doing up here what's
the bouncer dude why is it doing the
sound check
why is the bouncer covering google docs
yo dude
that's a good aka bouncer
[Music]
like hey why is the bouncer making fun
of the other bouncers
[ __ ]
yeah look at you [ __ ]
refrigerator how come these two bouncers
aren't taking care of the [ __ ] artist
dude after you're you're a successful
performance and you bow do you [ __ ]
hit a back tuck i i use i used to i
stopped doing that [ __ ] yeah can you
still do a flip anymore yeah i can still
do it i just choose not to you want to
have a flip off would you like to have a
clipboard why you know how to do it oh
yeah i do flips all the time i challenge
you i formally challenge you to flip off
well he's the only one laughing so he's
going to break something
he don't believe he'll break break
hearts
when's the last time you did a back tuck
just out of cold nothing like uh last
night like a few weeks ago wow yeah like
training or just for performing yeah
what did you do
i was watching too why were you upside
down for all you took him over
i was uh headlining the ontario improv
and someone shouted it out and it was a
really good show and i normally don't
[ __ ] do it but it it was the live the
vibe was good yeah they were i was like
they were great but they knew you
they're like we know this [ __ ] can
flip because nobody says that normally
yeah no one says it normally nobody's
like at the carl and show like hey i'll
do a flip
[Laughter]
later in his career
he does it he's all had the vibes right
yeah yeah it was a good night it was a
good night you ever like bust on a
girl's back and just do a back flip
what just butt naked
i i can't say that i'm doing that that's
a lot of work bro
yeah your legs are weak after yeah
you're like oh but he's a bouncer you
know what i mean
see ak works a second time i like it
you're sick [ __ ] really i hate
dancers i [ __ ] hate it
dance deserve it i'm gonna go back to
that side
of that side
don't leave me here alone man
can you really flip hell [ __ ] yeah
non-stop this is [ __ ] yeah i know right
yeah no one ever says
[ __ ] yeah okay so true story after you
bust on a girl's back he does true true
story i have very long legs right so
when i was in like [ __ ] third grade
or whatever it was
uh all the girls were doing gymnastics
and [ __ ] and i was like i don't want to
play the guys like [ __ ] girls are way
cool like i'm like super interested
girls girls
exactly
so then i was i was going over there and
then one of the girls her name was
amanda she's like she's like uh doing
flips and [ __ ] and she's like steve do
you think you could do a flip and i'm
like yeah [ __ ] yeah i could do a foot
really because it'll say [ __ ] yeah
so convincing honestly
i
i ran so [ __ ] hard and i jumped and i
tucked and i barely landed on by landing
the front on my tuck like on my left
like that basically like but with my
hands like digging into the dirt and
[ __ ] up my hands oh like like well i
have to go on the floor for it but like
this and you land you did a front tuck
front flip because those are even harder
than the back ones
well i i've never drank i mean those are
hard to pull out of your ass if you
can't do them
holy [ __ ] she was impressed she [ __ ]
loved it she was wet as hell
shouts out to amanda
exactly
wow but yeah uh but um backflips of me
no no i could never do that oh
i was i was kind of excited i'll do i'll
do a backflip with you if you want i
know you
situation very similar to this we're
just talking [ __ ] about do it
do it
don't you hate that when people like
that
all right hold on wait wait wait make
space make sure he's in frame make sure
the world can see is he in frame
yes he's in frame i gotta move this [ __ ]
i'm gonna help this whole body
he's in frame he's been he's 39 now
he's a 40 year old back flipper by the
way if you're worried about his medical
he's fine he's worth 18 million dollars
he'll be fine
[Applause]
you yeah yeah
no no one ever never no one ever bullies
me into a backbone
our vibes suck
the whole whole episode's just happening
you know when you haven't done him in a
while and then when you get to the
upside down point you just go blind no
okay well
it happened to me
i can't see
no i know what you're saying like we're
like
it's just like i don't know like and you
start to see the dots yeah
whatever i saw immediately what do you
guys do to warm up
he didn't do everything he talked yeah i
know right yeah few minutes he walked
over there it's always a good trick when
everyone in the audience goes
okay he's okay
it's like the circus circus sideshows
going on when you're trying to play you
landed on your head bro no one else has
tried a backflip that's kind of my thing
i have you have yeah i do when i was
younger i was able to but back flip back
nick in the video
and some blue cross
you